حسنًا ، جاهز في بعض الأحيان سيخبرني الناس أن
هذه هي المرة الأولى لي على متن طائرة مائية ، لذا
أحاول بذل المزيد من الجهد لجعلها أفضل
لوحة يمكنهم الحصول
عليها على الإطلاق ، سيستغرق الأمر 25 دقيقة من هنا
وقبل مغادرتي أود كسر
الأمان  ميزات المتصل هي نفسها
الطيارون حفاة القدمين لأننا عندما
نكون في الطائرة
نركل صندلنا ونطير حافي القدمين على
الدواسات ، فهذا يمنحك متعة رائعة حقًا
[موسيقى]
عندما أخبرت بعض أفراد العائلة والأصدقاء
أنني كنت أتمنى  تعال إلى جزر المالديف
للعمل ، فأول رد أحصل عليه هو أين يوجد
ذلك ، لذلك أوضح لهم دائمًا
إذا نظرت إلى الهند ونقطة الهند
من جانب هي سريلانكا وعلى
الجانب الآخر سلسلة طويلة من الجزر
تسمى  موديلات جزر المالديف
امتدت لمسافة تزيد عن 400 ميل
ولدينا منتجعات هناك بمسافة تصل إلى
180 ميلاً تقريبًا من هنا
والطريقة الوحيدة للوصول إليها هي بالطائرة
مرحبًا بك في coochie ، شكرًا لك ، أعتقد
أنه من المضحك أننا وجدنا
المطر الوحيد  في ال  ه جزر المالديف اليوم ، أيها الولد المناسب ،
لكن كل شيء بدأ الآن لا تقلق أي
شخص مقدسين خمس دقائق
، الاختلاف الرئيسي مع خطة التدفق
على عكس الطائرة ذات العجلات هو
العامل الممتع بالطبع ، إنه أكثر متعة
وتحديًا أعتقد على أي حال
للهبوط  على الماء لأن الماء يتغير دائمًا ،
يمكنك قضاء
يوم زجاجي تمامًا ويعتقد الجميع
أن هذه هي أسهل طريقة للهبوط ولكن هذا
ليس لأنه يعكس السماء ،
يجب أن تكون حذرًا للغاية عندما
تهبط في مياه زجاجية  الظروف لأنني
أعتقد أن الهبوط على مدرج مسطح هو نوع
من نظرة مملة بحيث يمكنك حقًا
رؤية المدرج
خلال وضح النهار 200 تقلع بعض
عمليات الهبوط هنا بطائراتنا
، نعم إنها مشغولة جدًا جيدًا ، نحن
فخورون حقًا بهذا المصنع يمكننا القول
هذا أن شركة Transmittivity Airways هي
أكبر مشغل للطائرات المائية في العالم
دون أدنى شك ، أعني بالنظر إلى
النافذة التي ربما تكون أكبر
فائدة هي الطقس وكل يوم
ومن الطائرة  ه ولكن هذا نحن
نطير فوق نفس المناطق ولكن
المشهد يغير الماء
أو تتغير الألوان أو تتغير الغيوم أو لا
أعرف كيف أصفها ولكن المنظر
من مكتبي هو الأفضل في العالم
[موسيقى]